WITHIN STRIKING DIFFERENCE.
TIFFANY SMILE YOULY WILL BE WITH
US.
OPEC PLUS SHOCKED THE FREE
WORLD.
HIGHER GAS PRICE FOR YOUR
VEHICLE.
NOT GOOD ON BOTH COUNTS.
YOU WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE TIME
FOR THE PRESIDENT TO GO BACK TO
TRUMP-LEVEL PRODUCTION.
OPEN UP FEDERAL LANDS, CUT AWAY
THE BUREAUCRACY.
AND FRACK OUR WAY BACK TO ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
BUT HE'S NOT.
WHAT'S THE REAL AGENDA.
THE PRESIDENT IS HELPING
DEMOCRAT INTERESTS, NOT AMERICAN
INTERESTS.
>> WE AGREE WE NEED TO BE LESS
DEPENDENT ON OPEC PLUS AND
FOREIGN PRODUCERS OF RESOURCES
LIKE OIL.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS WORKING SO
HARD ON CLEAN ENERGY SOLUTIONS,
THAT'S THE FUTURE.
>> THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
DEPENDENCY ON FOREIGN COUNTRIES
FOR AMERICAN OIL AND GAS IS A
CHOICE.
THE CHOICE THISSED A BEHIND
STRAITION HAS MADE REPEATEDLY.
BRIAN: NOT TO TRIAL ONSHORE OR
OFFSHORE.
NOT TO GIVE NEW LEASES AND THE
CHOICE TO GO GREEN WHEN GREEN IS
NOT READY.
BIDEN'S RUNS TO TWO ENEMY
NATIONS.
THE MILLION GALLONS A DAY ON THE
GLOBAL MARKET WOULD BRING PRICES
DOWN.
MOST RECENTLY LAW ENFORCEMENT
KILLING 100 PEOPLE PROTESTING
THE VICIOUS BEATING OF A WOMAN
BECAUSE SHE DIDN'T WEAR THE
RIGHT HIJAB OR DIDN'T PUT IT ON
CORRECTLY.
IT COULD ALSO PIVOT OVER TO
VENEZUELA.
A COUNTRY WHERE SECURITY FORCES
ARE ACCUSED OF TORTURING THEIR
PEOPLE WITH ELECTRIC SHOCKS ON
THEIR EYELIDS OR SUFFOCATING
THEM WITH CHEMICALS.
ONE COMMON CAUSE, THEY HATE
AMERICA.
THEY GO AGAINST THE GRAIN IN
EVERY WAY, SHAPE AND FORM.
>> I HAVE BEEN CLEAR HUMAN
RIGHTS MUST BE THE CENTER OF OUR
FOREIGN POLICY.
BRIAN: THERE WERE NO HUMAN
RIGHTS IN THOSE COUNTRIES.
HIGH OIL AND GAS PRICES WILL
MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE F